foreign
what is a good way to phrase that so if
someone wants to have not a mission
statement but some type of
state for this is the type of person I
want to be I think it's I'm the type of
person who blank for example so like I'm
the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts or I'm the type of person who
shows up on time or I'm the type of
person who finishes what they start
whatever aspect of your identity that
you're trying to reinforce that's kind
of the the story you can also phrase it
as a question so for example rather than
saying I'm the type of person who
doesn't miss workouts you could have
this question that's related to the
identity you want to build and you kind
of carry it around with you all day and
like in this example maybe the question
is what would a healthy person do and so
you're just kind of walking around all
day asking yourself you know what should
I get for lunch well what would a
healthy person do or should I take the
an Uber or should I walk to the next
meeting well what would a healthy person
do and you just kind of like go around
your day and try to make decisions that
you feel like support that identity but
I think you start with who is the type
of person I wish to become so let's say
I'm the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts and then the second step is
prove it to yourself with small wins so
which small actions what little habits
cast votes or being the kind of person
who doesn't miss workouts well maybe one
thing is
rather than doing a 45 minute workout
when I only have 10 minutes I reduce the
scope but stick to the schedule and I do
a couple Sprints or I do you know
five sets of push-ups or whatever it is
and so you find ways to
reinforce your desired identity even if
it's small especially in the beginning
because if you can show up consistently
if you kind of Master the art of showing
up and Performing these small habits you
build up this sense of momentum you kind
of start to reinforce and shape that new
identity and the more evidence that you
have for it
at some point you kind of cross this
invisible threshold where you're like oh
I guess I am that kind of person you
know like if you go out and shoot a
basketball for five minutes you don't
think oh I'm the basketball player but
if you do it every day for six months or
a year or two years like at some point
you cross this invisible line you're
like you know I guess playing basketball
is kind of part of who I am so I think
you're trying to accumulate
actions that support your desired
identity